he could be a [ __ ] piece of [ __ ]
whatever you're like i would never date
this guy but then because you had sex
with him then your brain's like
maybe i could make this work
you know yeah
maybe i can make him a husband
[Music]
hello welcome back to big mood everybody
we have a special special special guest
today
the one and only the beautiful the
magical nikki blaze
oh you guys get the best intro
you guys love nikki we freaking love
nikki not this one i love mickey oh
andrew
yeah we're so excited we get to have her
for a whole day yeah
so make sure you tune back in because
she'll be popping in every apple
episodes throughout yeah we'll kind of
schedule them we'll spread it out
with them we'll save this
we were talking before uh filming about
how you um you got a whole new look
going since the last time we saw you
chopped off all the ugly blondes
these [ __ ] were telling me how i'm
just no longer trending
out of fashion
i was sticking with you like one foot at
one foot out with the blonde tips that i
had but i topped them all off yeah so
why did you go back to the dark side
you really want to know
yes it's a great story so it was on the
set of tim's music video there's a whole
story there's a story i'm so excited i
had already been contemplating so i dyed
my hair after a breakup and i watched we
do you know
we had the same haircut
and i was already kind of like i don't
know i think i want to go back to dark
but again i've already been in this for
two years once you are this color
it's an investment and i was there
oh my god all the time shout out to my
girl andrea because she got me to that
point but then i was like you know what
um i'm not feeling it
but the day came and so i was on set
with tim shooting his music video and
some of the cast members in the back
were like talking and then they look
they're talking and then they look and
i'm like
what's up yeah
they're like we're just trying to figure
out what you are i'm like
here we go again why do people care so
much they care a lot with mixed they
care they care it's just like whatever
you want it's a mystery it's a mystery
so they're just looking at me and
they're giving me this like strange look
and one of the guys goes
are you just white and i'm like
because the blonde there's that's it
you think that's it he's like
yeah there's no way according to your
face that you are just white thank you
that's coming from a 100 white person
people are wild out there you know
that's true because like yeah white
people when you look at you know
the darker people look at you and go
you're you're maybe white like maybe
full white i'm like oh
so they're like well you're just white
because you're just caucasian even
though you have an ethnic spaniards
conquered the aztecs
brown people were oppressed in this mix
being a brown person a very proud woman
of color i was like
excuse me i'm trying not to be offended
right now because
you didn't say i was not pretty but she
said but you just say you look white
i was just taken back
my dad is pissed
i didn't mix you up for that
you better be proud of all the things
you've got
so
when he said that and the girl's looking
at me she's like
oh my god i see it now and i'm like the
[ __ ] are you two yeah yeah i have no
idea but literally after that day
i hit up my friend and i said
what do i look like to you like do i
look did i look different when my hair
was dark versus when it's blonde i feel
like so they said you look more
approachable as a blonde i was like oh
okay but that's not what the people said
and so when she was like yeah you do
look you do look lighter these days and
i was like you know what it's time hmm
back to the dark side i was like nope
i'm going back dark wait why is blonde
look more approachable yeah well that
works for me too right didn't you that's
true oh yeah you did
judge i said
judge judy's daughter
judicial
i don't know that is interesting she's
gonna sentence me if i talk to her that
was one of one of the things i wanted to
do when i went blonde because i wanted
to be
maybe like if i feel like i look happier
brighter or lighter on the outside maybe
i'll feel it on the inside yeah so that
was kind of like the process and i was
like okay i wore less makeup i wasn't
wearing as much dark colors i kind of
dressed you know for my hair more
highlighters just like peachy and i
really just felt softer so yeah i was
like okay that's exactly what i was
going for with it but i didn't like it
because i felt like that was fake i was
like damn i feel like you're putting on
all my skiing yeah i totally was masking
so that was just yeah just let your dark
energy flow
that was like the perfect excuse because
i was like okay cool i'm ready to go
back to like dark hair blades yeah be in
my zone wear my colors and not
feel bad for it you know like not worry
like if i look like a [ __ ] good don't
[ __ ] talk to me though
i'm being authentic
cool
that's weird because like even when you
were blonde or with the dark hair now to
me i look at you and i would guess i
wouldn't guess what you actually have in
you which is some like pacific islanders
so i would have guessed like maybe like
a quarter black and like half mexican or
something like i wouldn't i would never
think
yeah i get everything
i just say whatever you are or whatever
you grew up around is probably what you
think i am yeah you know what i mean
i'm just used to seeing it that's true
because i got like whenever i would go
to glendale for whatever reason oh yeah
a lot of you do i was saying you didn't
armenian girl i please i thought it was
armenian yeah a first poker with a bunch
of armenians and they totally just
talked armenian to me and i'm like oh
sorry
that's just what i've learned i mean and
i can't i used to get upset about it for
a while when people are like oh you're
not asian or you don't look asian and i
just take it as ignorance because people
are just always yeah they only know
people will only think east asian well
like they only know what they know yeah
like let's be real i can't be mad at
somebody who's never seen a hawaiian
before right let alone somebody who's
super mixed i mean look at look at the
tvs and look at the magazines how often
are you actually seeing people
tell you exactly what they are so that
they can relate like they're not you're
forced to pick a side so i'm like i
never want to do that i always say what
i am because i know there's other people
out there that are like oh my god me too
i wish i saw somebody that's exactly how
i feel i feel like it's gotten a little
better yeah at least on tv and seeing a
little bit more of us diversity yeah
reflected but
as a kid yeah i was all like blonde
white or like you're a foreigner yeah
you know for the people that don't know
what exactly is your full like i think
background i'm hawaiian chinese filipino
irish then there's sprinkles of other
stuff but you know you do the
twenty-three like all asians yeah yeah i
mean
not what i would expect yeah
but the pacific islanders where the
darkness comes out yeah and the filipino
side yeah you know we never get counted
as asian people like
yeah yeah well because filipinos and
this is a big debate because
filipinos like to go to the pacific
islander side but they're not yeah
they're they're that's true they're more
asian so even within my this half of my
box i'm still not in a box yeah
and it's really confusing but
mixed people have to have conversations
too because if we don't say something
then how is anybody gonna know like us
growing up i grew up in a very mixed
household like hawaiian style is
different than hawaiian yeah hawaiian
style is like local versus speaking like
to garlic japanese chinese and had no
idea like i'm using these words
regularly because that's like local
style then i moved to the bay area and
there was like actual filipinos out
there because i grew up in the valley
there was like nobody really was
filipino so i'm out there like oh you're
filipina and then you're saying all
these words i'm like oh i grew up
speaking this but i didn't realize what
it was because it was just local style
or when i go have japanese food and i'm
saying a lot of the same things but i
never
was able to separate it because i didn't
know and that's just kind of how it was
in our house we just were what we were
and it's like
you just go about your day i relate to
that a tiny little bit because i grew up
saying
english words chicanofide oh okay
spanglish so i used to think that
complication cracks me up
so i thought that the word for cereal
and spanish was cornflakes
i didn't know this until it was like way
too old
and i was like oh my god this is
embarrassing like what else did i not
know that it wasn't spanish but i was
using it as if it was spanish but it was
like spanglish like chica is it would it
be chicano language is that a thing kind
of like i guess with pigeon pigeon yeah
it's kind of the same it you know it has
its own lane we have our own words it's
like our own version of like hawaiian
like just last night i was telling um i
was i forgot it was either nikki or gina
but oh gina i was like oh are you gonna
go mimi's and then she's like what i'm
like are you gonna go to sleep like
mimi's means it's like slaying for like
the word
is like to go to sleep in spanish and
then casey asked me like wait is that
like chicano or is it like mexican like
do you mexican see me yes or just
chicago and i was like sitting there
like [ __ ] i don't know yeah i don't know
i don't remember saying mimi's in
mexico so maybe it is a chicano thing i
don't know yeah and it's just like a lot
of these words we've so
to go to sleep in hawaiian is momoy
so like gomo moi so like my nieces
sounds so close yeah and a lot of the
words are really similar if you look at
like just like language in general
so mamoy or like honey honey is kiss so
like growing up we had certain yeah
everything's like repeated yeah we only
got
[Laughter]
i don't know why we got a whole ass
thing for a space yeah that's all i know
is it's a breath yeah it's a pause
so we have that but yeah growing up is
just throwing all these different words
around and then
mind you a lot of my friends
were mexican growing up so speaking
spanish and then you're throwing like
mexican like mexican inc like spanish
you know that's a whole yeah you all
know that's that's a whole different
thing because people get upset went to
puerto rico once used the wrong spanish
they were laughing at me i was like
y'all are so mean don't you see what are
you drawing
yeah i don't know what you're doing
completely because then you could also
look like cuban or something too when
the hair is curly yeah
[Applause]
but it was it was similar but different
because when i grew up it was a lot of
white people and that and i got actually
really mad at the words because we would
use it mix in filipino like tagalog and
and my mom grew up in hawaii so then
there was like pigeon type of words in
there too and i don't even know if like
it was really tagalog or like thrown in
words and so
like there were certain words that we
always called things so like uh penis
and vagina were pcoy's penis and and
punani is vagina yeah and so when
some kids at school were talking about
like vagina and penis they were using
those words i was like what is that yeah
and i was like no that's that's a punani
like i was like kidding me feeling mad
i've never heard the words vagina or
penis in my life and they're all
giggling and laughing at me and then
they like they started bullying me so i
go home i'm so mad because like i'm like
i know i'm right like we've never called
anything that yeah and then i go home
and i'm like yelling to my mom about it
and she's like you know kind of laughing
but also like oh this is actually like
yeah the english version
i was so [ __ ] pissed i was like
i need to know exactly what the words
are yeah
[Applause]
and then go into like the whole like
what we wear what we're eating yeah he's
like it's just all types of confusion
yeah type but then we call sometimes i
don't know what language this is but we
call it boto
that could be could be
samoan i don't know but we call it like
a bottle what is it that's a penis oh
like you know that's your like that's
your both
but i don't know
where it even comes from yeah because
like my friends from hawaii came up to
the 49er game what i want to say like a
couple weeks ago and they're all local
so all local but they if you stood them
all up they're not hawaiian but they're
hawaiian but they're local i would just
say everybody's local i don't know what
their actual background is because then
there's not that many actual indigenous
hawaiians yeah yeah
yeah so you know but they're all local
styles so when you're listening to them
talk and there's things that i'm going
whoo
you can't be saying that out loud in
front of everybody over here because you
sound crazy and it's okay because i
realize like some of the stuff just in
general the words just sound wild
sometimes and i was like i can turn it
on and turn it off because when i'm with
my dad it's on full like oh my god my
dad's english is so [ __ ] like
my dad types in his accent
i was like my
and we're like grandma what's pi
and she's like pipe it's pi but we're
like that's not a word what's pipe and
you know that has a lot of like uh
points on the p and the b you get
that's not a word and she's like one two
three four five
five
tree tree
what you mean what is that yeah so every
so all the time like the words i have no
idea where they actually come from but i
use them like just regularly and then
when you get around certain people the
words just flow and you're like okay we
were talking about eating food too like
i was getting mad because there was that
conversation where i was like fighting
them about words and then i had the
conversation with my parents like you
better tell me like all the words that
are other words too yeah and they'd
never be embarrassed again yeah yeah and
then we were eating like this kid was
eating egg rolls and i was like lumpia
and he's like no and i was like yeah
it's [ __ ] lupia
where's the egg
like an asian kid like a guy
from panda express with the fortune
cookie i'm just here for the sweet and
sour sauce
isaac has his friend he's like this
little white kid he's super cute and
he um he was telling isaac he was like
hey let's go eat some chinese food
there's like this ramen spot and then
isaac was like
chinese food ramen isn't chinese it's
japanese there's
nobody
yeah exactly so then and then isaac was
like he kind of reminded me of little
nicky because then
he was like yeah i've been to japan
such a capricorn
the food is the food is the tough one
food
growing up because again i didn't grow
up around like any fast food restaurants
not really any other restaurants and in
our house it was you know hawaiian food
or local style food so like top ramen is
simon
so we have simon we call it simon is
there like peas or something don't y'all
make it different uh we put like fish
cake
uh spam egg okay i didn't know ramen was
japanese because i grew up with cup of
noodles so you'd be like oh just heat up
a cup of noodles like you just call it
we would call it cup of noodles uh like
just like with golden flavors even
though they matter
oh yeah oh no like for us like we just
call everything by the brand name like
if we wanted a tampon and be like oh you
have a cortex
like we just called it
imagine getting another uh pad brand in
your house you're like what is this
no not even like we don't even care
about the brand it's the product it's
called cortex got it it's like
kleenex yeah we all always say kleenex
yeah speaking of brands we have quite a
few
for you to check out that might enhance
your life they will enhance your life so
listen to future us talking about it so
we've been in the new year for a couple
weeks now and some of you might have
broken your new year's resolutions
already maybe instantly maybe instantly
yeah especially if there were health and
fitness goals perhaps and that's because
one of the biggest aspects of studying
health and fitness goals which is the
psychology behind it yeah and that's
where we'd like to thank our sponsor
newm who really focuses on the
psychology-based approach to help people
better understand your relationship with
food your relationship to your body your
relationship to fitness and like really
why you do the things you do like really
help you examine
do a deep dive on yourself and your
habits because you're never gonna
achieve your goals if you don't change
your habits
at least not not long term noom will
teach you how to be more mindful with
the way that you eat and give you the
skills and knowledge that you need to
build long lasting and positive habits
which is really what you want in long
run you don't just want it for this year
you want it for life with my personal
experience uh with nume i didn't really
realize how my habits were snacking when
bored snacking when stressed and
snacking when filled with anxiety never
ever had to do with hunger never had to
do with actually needing sustenance
emotions but just emotions and i never
thought i was an emotional eater because
i didn't eat when i was sad i wasn't
like one of those people crying with ice
cream or whatever um but boredom and
stress eating is a real thing and i had
to really check myself they had me do
like a food journal for a little bit so
you can actually see because it's easy
to forget that you do that stuff you're
not counting it as a full meal because
you just grabbed it
when you weren't thinking when you were
stressing out about something that was
due yeah and you don't count it as part
of your intake um so really looking at
that and and examining like what makes
you do the things that you do what makes
me need to have a drink in my hand when
i'm at a social event when i didn't
really need a drink um and then helping
you to break that a healthier life
doesn't mean sticking to rules about
what you can and can't eat it just means
having more knowledge to build smarter
more sustainable habits gnome uses a
cognitive behavioral approach that
focuses on the why instead of the what
to help you change your relationship
with food and everyone's journey looks
different so don't judge yourself don't
be hard on yourself and the thing i like
the most about noom is that it's only 10
minutes a day you don't need to commit
your whole day to it you don't need to
be like i need to reserve two hours for
the gym and driving and parking and all
that stuff no 10 minutes a day you can
change a huge part of your life and your
lifestyle noom fits into anyone's life
on on your own terms and there's no
grueling early mornings or large chunks
of your day taken out start building
better habits for healthier long-term
results sign up for your trial today at
noom that's n-o-o-m dot com slash big
mood that's
n-o-o-m.com big mood to sign up for your
trial today okay so maybe you've tried
to uh do better in life maybe you're
eating clean now yeah well that's good
but are you cleaning clean
you might not know it but we may be
eating a credit card's worth of plastic
each week thanks to the tons and tons of
single-use plastic that we throw out
every week blue land is trying to fix
that blue land was founded on the belief
that a cleaner planet starts at home
it's a simple idea buy the bottle once
and refill it forever no more constant
plastic waste from their best-selling
clean essentials kit to their hand soap
duo blue land offers safe smart options
for every inch of your home just fill
blue lands beautiful instagramable
bottles with warm water pop in one of
the hand soap or spray cleaner tablets
and within minutes you'll have powerful
effective cleaning products in the most
incredible sense like rose bergamot or
lily mint and now blue land has teamed
up with disney to create a magical
collection of hand soap forever bottles
designed with mickey and friends
whimsical personalities in mind how cute
blue lands stunning high quality forever
bottles start at just 10 when you buy a
kit and are meant to be used and reused
forever with money-saving refill tablets
that are only two dollars that's awesome
two dollars and up but they start at two
dollars i love how cute their products
are yeah yeah it makes me clean yeah so
cute the way to get a millennial to buy
something is to make it make it yeah
and honestly like in my home i've been
doing my best to to find places where i
can get rid of plastic and replace it
with natural materials like glass or
cloth or whatever like anything that i
have that seems like it's kind of fake
i've been trying to replace everything
with like
forever materials so i like the
direction that this is going and you buy
these are plastic bottles but they're
very thick and you just buy them once
yeah they're very sturdy bottles that
you just re-using i love it so you cut
the plastic waste
without sacrificing clean get blue land
you'll love it and the planet will thank
you right now you can get 15 off your
first order when you go to blueland.com
big mood that's 15 off your first order
of any products at blue land go to
blueland.com big mood blueland.com
big mood wow i really want to buy
everything you're selling oh thank you
yeah use the codes
and you could go get all you hook
yourself up i need for a good time oh
that's what i'll do
i'm gonna listen into the future
episodes where you talk about all the
codes oh yeah yeah yeah there we go we
made them for you to hook us up what
else is going on in your life
oh okay what how's your you wouldn't do
that breakup yeah how's your dating like
what is this is it still hurtful you
can't talk about breakup no actually i'm
like in a really good space good really
really good space is that space
including a man or is that on your own
it's on my own okay yeah yeah yeah it's
been she's like no comments
it's just work right now is taking over
everything like i have as it should you
know and it's what i want to take over
yeah because if i want to have a
relationship i can prioritize it i
definitely can find the time it exists
it's it's there i have a lot of it but
i just know i'm not ready for somebody
else's emotions yeah i cannot be
responsible for somebody else's you know
feelings right now because i'm still so
self-absorbed and needing to worry about
my own and just figuring out my days
that i would be a shitty girlfriend it's
not right time for me yeah and when the
person comes along or maybe when the
situation
you know or i'm like hey i'm ready then
i'll probably get out and date but i'm
chilling i think right now i have a lot
of amazing people in my life i got solid
like almost anybody i know right now i
could pick up the phone and call one in
the morning and it's not even a matter
like who come through it's like
now let's talk or just
good friends and good connections
stimulating conversation yeah and i i
want to stress to our younger like girls
that watch this show like can you
explain like kind of how you got to that
point because i think like a lot of
girls they'll call in they'll be like i
i just broke up with him like my life is
terrible now like i miss him so much
like i don't even know how to move
forward like how do you get to that
point to where you're you feel like your
life is whole
and it's does and it's not whole because
of a boyfriend right okay so i'm not
gonna sugarcoat this [ __ ] at all it is
[ __ ]
hard okay it don't come with a manual it
don't come with a timeline it really
is something you just have to go through
and you have to put yourself as the
priority every single day it's a
reminder you have to be on top of
yourself to remind yourself of what you
want like yeah if you're
if you're feeling like you're incomplete
without that person you're always going
to feel incomplete without that person
20 years can go by and you can still be
like i'm missing you could be in a whole
ass other relationship still in love
with that person because you never
healed because you never wanted to being
able to make yourself happy on your own
is the biggest like lesson to get
through because once you get that once
you're like i'm happy genuinely happy on
my own that's when someone comes in that
enhances your life you know you're not
ready to like you you won't want to
settle on someone that's going to take
away from that happiness that you built
for yourself you'll only want to be with
someone that adds to it and it'll be
natural it'll be the path of least
resistance once that happens but so many
people
i think aren't willing to be alone and
like work on that and find that because
they get so scared with this like
this middle unknown air space of time
yeah and it's so important it's like and
it's so fulfilling and like um enriching
to your life to be able to have that and
know that you have that because no one
could ever take that away from you once
you have it you know last week was a
really hard mental week for me it was
just a tough mental week and i've
learned to forgive myself for those days
and i've allowed myself to just have
that day like okay
you're not gonna probably make it to the
gym don't even try to force it because
now you're gonna guilt-trip yourself
because you didn't go like stop beating
yourself up i think it was a solid two
days for some reason i was just sad like
just
really sad and i just had to feel it and
i just had to remember like don't turn
to like over drinking i'm not trying to
like use other drugs or i'm not trying
to use sex or yeah don't take something
to fill that right just embrace that i
just had to feel it and honestly it was
just and it goes away it's temporary
it's tempting that's what you forget is
like when you're going through either a
depression or something like it's
everything's temporary even though it
feels like forever but the more you try
to cover it up the longer it will last
yeah you need to allow yourself to
process it you know that book um the
body keeps the score it talks a lot
about how we have a natural cycle yeah
there's a natural cycle for emotions and
for
just like whatever stress that you're
feeling or trauma there's usually a a
cycle and you have to let it end but
then how people get stuck in trauma is
because
they're not letting the psychological
yeah like that you don't let yourself
feel the emotions that you have to feel
that's why in therapy too like whenever
there's um situations that are brought
up like at least my therapist is always
like so what are you feeling in your
body yeah like what do you feel right
now like how does it like you just sit
with that emotion and then that's why my
neck is tight tell me what that means
that's how you let it go
because as long as you're just like
avoiding it or whatever that's how it
grows and stays bigger and it just
creates more problems and it and you'll
crash like there's been times where
it just felt like it was so much and i
was like i just need to go out or i need
to do this and it wasn't with the right
intention it was to mask whatever was
going on let me tell you
dim drinks
bring out the tears
in places you don't need to be crying at
because you just didn't deal with what
you're feeling yeah and it's okay i
think the process of going through a
breakup
you have to make it just about you
and you have to
some people like to write i i used to
write but i i don't as much anymore i'm
more of a talker i like to talk through
it or think through it so
while i'm dealing with all these
emotions you have to understand like if
you are holding on to a breakup because
of what somebody else did to you and
you're looking for something from them
you got to understand like it's probably
not going to come and even if you get
quote-unquote closure it's still not
going to feel the way you want it to
feel you never really know what that
thing that's going to make you feel
better is until you just stumble across
it yeah and you have to just keep trying
things you have to keep
finding a reason to
want to be happy like why because it's
easy to be sad let me tell you being sad
is one of the easiest things to do it is
extremely difficult to be happy for a
lot of people they struggle with just
being happy then let alone comparison
right you pick up your phone you see
relationships you see girls being single
you're like oh my god how are they doing
it well they're also not showing a lot
of the other stuff that's happening you
know and it's ugly and it hurts and it's
dark but throughout that process you end
up finding out who you actually are
because maybe you didn't even know who
you were in your relationship one of the
toughest things i had to do was sit with
myself and be like what do you actually
like like yes like what do you like
without someone else's influence yeah
you know you get you have to know what
you want to know when you get it oh my
god because otherwise you're just going
bouncing from person to person or what
situation situation
you know when people are like no
whatever uh i'll do whatever you want to
do yeah
you have to when there's nobody else
responsible for your happiness you can't
blame somebody for not doing what you
wanted to do or have somebody to argue
with it's only you and that's a trippy
ass realization when you're like
oh [ __ ]
i'm sad because i chose not to do
anything today yeah yeah i decided that
i'm stressed out because i didn't
organize my own stuff like oh [ __ ] i'm
responsible for my own my own emotions
and my own life and the organization or
disorganization and that is a crazy
thing because you can really feel alone
in that moment but then you also realize
that you got you you know you're only
going to be let down if you let yourself
down and learning to fix it like
learning to work through those
situations is like that you're building
a toolbox
and so next time you're in a situation
like that you're like oh i'm i'm okay
because i've gone through this before
and this is what i did and yeah okay i
got this yeah i feel more confident and
becoming self-aware the biggest thing
and i think the
greatest takeaway from dealing with the
breakup is being able to sit with
yourself
it is hard people don't want to have to
face the things that they did wrong they
don't want to face their faults and
faith a little bit of the the um the
chemical
withdrawal yes like the that's a huge
part that for me i think was the hardest
part was the chemical withdraw like you
literally become addicted yes chemically
to a person and so you think that you
need them but really you're just an
addict you're going you're going to be
going through a detox yeah and when
you're going through withdrawals if
anybody's ever experienced that it it's
there's reasons why people
kind of don't make it through that phase
and you go right back because it is hard
you're heroin kind of your body is
literally like
beating it
yeah it's like it's fighting itself
right now and you know that you can fix
it for them to send you a text or
something just yeah that dopamine yeah
again yeah it's so
hard everything is like right there i
want to reach out i mean i've definitely
relapsed like throughout this process
but
that's a part of it it's literally a
part of it when you learn though like
after you do relapses and then you come
down again and you're like oh why did i
yeah then like next time maybe you won't
do it and then there's more time goes by
totally it's easier to not relapse yeah
because it's not a perfect process
yeah and everybody's process is going to
be different like my ex and i are civil
but i can tell you this right now like
i caught myself doing something that i
knew was going to piss me off
and then i was like
do you want to just i had to go do you
just want to be mad today because that's
what you're about to do but you know go
ahead and look at this story it's
saturday night
it's three in the morning let's see what
the [ __ ] this asshole's up to what's
that gonna make me do
and guess what when i was drinking i was
like oh i'm gonna call him out oh you
get [ __ ] never mind and i just was like
you know you actually both girls but it
was like man you know you actually don't
even like that man no more you just
bored yeah but then i had to realize
like i was just bored and i wanted
attention that's great for you to
realize that i love that i'll be talking
to myself like
you better go find you a friend or daddy
so many people don't realize that they
they stay self-righteous and they're
like mm-hmm i'm gonna show him and it's
like why are you doing this why you
doing most of your life
you end up hurting yourself toxic people
know how to be toxic people
it's the ones trying to not be toxic
anymore so if say you are a toxic person
i have very i got a long list of toxic
traits that i am working on but i am
great in a toxic relationship i know all
the games
[Applause]
but you're gonna love the [ __ ] out of me
like this is gonna be the best time of
your life but we might die in the
process
uh but i got [ __ ] to do now and i got a
job so you know i can't be acting yeah
i'm a dog mom these days yes
i have somebody who cares about me yeah
but
but
that is so easy to be
it's so it really is it's easier just
it's like a
high school thing yeah you could just
stay there forever because you've been
training on it you've been training for
it and guess what there's always going
to be somebody that's ready to be toxic
with you and to feed into that [ __ ]
because they don't want to grow up
either but also it's exciting but but
toxic life is an exciting [ __ ] girl i
got goosebumps yeah i understand she did
i did i got
adrenaline it is it's it's a drug
addiction totally it's what it is but
there's nothing worse than a toxic
person yeah meeting someone who is
self-aware and does not feed into it and
you're like oh [ __ ]
i need to grow up yeah or let me
rephrase that not necessarily grow up
like i need to work on myself
you know and because i've met i met
somebody and that [ __ ] just wasn't
flying and it was like whoa okay like
you're not feeding into it you don't
like it you actually find it really
unattractive damn i really like this
person i value this person i admire so
many qualities about this person and
they are looking at me like
see i like a lot of things about you but
you still got some work to do
and you know that's cool like hey that's
great you work on you but you come back
because i don't got time like i don't
have time for that mm-hmm and then you
really go oh [ __ ] yeah i i need to
reevaluate it it hurts more than if they
just played the game
anymore
and again everybody has their different
moments on this journey like i've come
across people that i
looked at and said i want to be like you
because of
because i know i can like those
qualities i don't want like not your job
you're right not your family it's like
you as a person you have really great
qualities about you and so throughout
the healing process i surrounded myself
with people i admired that's great yeah
you know like yeah and i also had to
look at the only way to get out of that
quicksand man and it's really tough
because you're going to lose friends in
this process like you're really going to
lose people who aren't on the same path
as you yeah you just moved your you guys
went to different levels yeah yeah and
it doesn't mean that you don't love them
and sometimes like again with family or
with friends you have to remove yourself
because you're enabling them just as
much as they're enabling you
but you've got to communicate it right
like if you just ghost somebody out of
the blue and they ask you what happened
and you don't explain yourself then
you're still continuing the process of
being like talks that's not totally you
know but again because you might inspire
them to want to change right you're if
you're now the person that's like hey i
love you but like there's this this and
this and i just don't have time right
now anymore again and
being selfish isn't a bad thing we have
to like break that stigma of thinking
that because we use a word selfish so
negatively but you're the only person
that you really need to take care of
yeah because if you're not whole you
can't
give that to anybody else people
conflate being selfish with like taking
things from other people but it's more
about like just
not not setting boundaries but yeah just
like putting up your own minds once you
realize the boundaries where you're like
i'm not willing to
fall below this standard of living or
like interacting with people then
it's i guess you can call it selfish but
it really is just like you just putting
your foot down and prioritizing yourself
yeah you know maybe we'll say that like
you got to prioritize yourself what are
you feeling i had a bunch of girls that
are on there you know demon time [ __ ]
right now that wanted to go yeah you
know what i mean like they single and
they are ready to shmingle these girls
it was halloween
but so the girls wanted to go out and
they're on demon time for me that's not
where my head was what do you call demon
time demon time is like yo we up we're
going to after hours you know the ball
players are at the table we popping
bottles [ __ ]
having a girl tonight like a girl you
know she's like demon time it's just
like i'm the [ __ ] let's go it's all
talks when you first said i thought you
were talking about your period because i
was like i was like oh yeah i get demon
time for show
okay that's not that talking about like
that
i'm a [ __ ] you're literally up to no
sexual all craziness yeah you're like
drunken like [ __ ] dudes
totally yeah which my girls i'm like
that's what you all need right now one
thousand percent get it
for me personally i was going through
some [ __ ] with work with fat with life
i'm just reevaluating stuff and i was
like look i love y'all but this is a bad
time i can't be in vegas right now like
i really can't because it's not going to
be good for me like i'm not trying to
ruin nobody's time but where my mentals
at right now
is this is that's not the environment i
want to be in like i didn't do anything
on halloween i stayed home well the day
before i spent time with family because
that's what i needed to do it had
nothing to do with me flaking on my
friends or not going because i explained
it to them i said yo my mental state is
not solid right now and
vegan and that's the type of selfish
that's perfectly expensive
because you're not taking anything from
them you're just giving them their space
but also taking your own because your
own is more important and when you have
solid people around you they understand
that and because that conversation maybe
a few years back with a different group
of girls would have been like oh my god
yeah nikki doesn't want to go on the
girls trip again she's over here not
wanting to hang out with everybody it
could have been completely different but
the girls were like okay cool
and i don't feel any type of way and
they don't feel anything yeah it's not
personal yeah but i needed to do that
because say
i was on some like [ __ ] him i want to go
out because he's probably going to look
at my instagram yeah yeah yeah dude do
you see you know and when we're doing
those types of things you're hurting
yourself and it's not even for me it's
for the other person like i'm doing this
to try to look good and i'm not even
having fun there's a difference yeah i'm
going out and i'm unbothered i've done
that so many times in my 20s like just
purposefully in spite of getting [ __ ]
up like hooking up with someone like
kind of just so maybe they'll they'll
hear about it like you know like it's
it's really it it's like you're you're
cutting yourself every time you know
like people to cut themselves you just
want to feel pain like that's what
you're doing it's like you know having
that behavior in witchcraft it's like
whatever you put on them comes two times
three yeah it's like it's like that yeah
it's like you're putting it on them but
it's coming back to you it's not gonna
make them want you again no if it does
it's just temporary so they can see if
they can still get in and then they'll
just get right back out anyways
and every breakup is different every
relationship is different just like
everybody's journey but it's like the
the basics of the journey of trying to
become okay with yourself is first off
you gotta actually know who you are
take the time to learn about yourself
also you gotta dig into the things that
you don't like about yourself like why
did i do those things like why was i
attracted to those people why do i self
sabotage you know why am i holding
myself back from being in better
situations like why do i keep subjecting
myself to like a trash ass group of
friends because i think i'm like that
you know like really looking in the
mirror and it's probably one of the
hardest things to do but that's really
the starting point because there's going
to be hard days there's going to be days
that you're like [ __ ] you take two steps
back
you're gonna take five steps forward
then you take two steps back but as long
as you're walking i think that's the
main thing to keep in mind no matter if
the steps are forward or backwards
you're still walking which means that
you have somewhere to go so you just
keep
who is the person you want to be that's
the person i want i have a question yeah
so how you're saying that you're not in
a relationship but
uh the dick is somewhere near you
how how does that feel for you like do
you feel like do you regret it when you
do that because it's not a relationship
or are you like are you because for me
it's i've been having a hard time
like
with being single not in a relationship
one of relationships kind of saving
myself mostly for a relationship yeah
but like a hookup will come here there
and then i'm like oh maybe i should have
done that like how do you how do you
deal with the feelings like
balancing keeping the dick around while
you're still focusing on yourself yeah
so the person that i'm talking to like i
have one person that i'm talking yeah
talking to that's my that's my d but you
know that it's not going anywhere but i
don't know that's messy and then the
thing is like i don't know what it is
and so
one of the reasons why i was super sad
the other night is because i wasn't
entertaining other people and i wanted
to entertain other people because i was
sad
but i was in my mind i was like i really
don't because i know how that makes me
feel i actually just want this person
maybe i need to just sit in this being
alone type thing the [ __ ] ain't easy
like it really ain't but breaking
breaking patterns yes really
it's tough i know i easily can hit
somebody up and i'm gonna feel bad later
yeah and i hate the lie like thinking of
the lie like what am i gonna say what
happens if that person actually does hit
me up it's constantly like
anxiety yeah it builds up in you but
like i've had times where it's like yeah
i'm sleeping with somebody and there's i
know there's not going to be a
relationship but that's also because i
my selfish needs was i needed that
physical touch that's what i wanted it
was with somebody that was on the same
page that's the only time it's never
really
hurt because i knew exactly what it was
the time it hurts is when you think
there's a potential relationship that's
when how do you stop yourself from even
like knowing
this person's not going to be a
relationship material i know what i'm
going into but physically when i touch
them and we're together and then i
[ __ ] i'm in his bed and then yeah he
could be a [ __ ]
piece of [ __ ] whatever you're like i
would never date this guy but then
because you had sex with him then your
brain's like
maybe i could make this work you know
we are fighting ourselves every [ __ ]
day our hormones don't help us at all
and especially that too because like one
week he ain't [ __ ] the next week you're
like i'm about to sit on his face
and then you get off and you're like
whoa i'm tripping you know it's just
like right it's just a wave of [ __ ]
feelings but you have to fight it if you
realistically weigh out the pros and the
cons and i think i was just talking to
somebody about that too
that's where you got to do the sit down
you got to separate your emotions um and
just like look at what you really want
if you know that the person your ideal
relationship is not that guy then you
know your path you still gotta walk
towards yeah you know you took a detour
don't mean you can't get right back onto
it you know take a pit stop you gotta
put some gas gotta put some fuel in the
tank gotta keep you chugging along in
order to get to your destination but
it's you got it it's like this whole
self-talk thing because
you know you don't want to be with them
you know that you're your vagina's the
only thing that wants them you know your
body's lying to you so you got to be
like
stupid people actually not up here you
gotta be like hey [ __ ] yeah yeah hey
punani you know what you're going to say
look
we know he's we know you just got to be
like i know girl i know
but it's not what we need you know that
right you'd be like you know you ain't
the only one right like he's good for a
reason so
you kind of have to just talk yourself
through it because dee will make you
cool girl
i still miss him
so i still miss you you know who you are
i miss you well something to get your
mind off him might be checking out some
of our sponsors oh yes um which future
is about to talk about right now you
know we deserve to know what we put in
our bodies especially
what we're putting in our bodies every
single day like a vitamin yes that's why
ritual is amazing uh they actually
put in so much work into the research
for their multivitamins specifically
their rituals essential for women 18 and
over multivitamin it was formulated by
exhaustive research to help fill
nutrient gaps in the diets of women ages
18 and up it is formulated with
nutrients to help support brain health
bone health blood health and provide
anti-oxidant support but rachel didn't
just stop there they invested in a gold
standard
university-led clinical trial to prove
the impact of essential for women 18 and
over multivitamin and the results they
found that it was shown to increase
vitamin d levels by 43
and omega-3 dha levels by 41 that's huge
in 12 weeks
yeah because there are night over 97 of
women aged 19 to 50 that are not getting
enough vitamin d
from their diet and 95 are not getting
the recommended daily intake of key
omega-3s yeah so that's why rituals
essential for women 18 and over
multivitamin is amazing because it could
help fill those gaps
rituals committed to third-party testing
from usp and the non-gmo project with
their traceable and vegan friendly
ingredients and it's always clear
communication they don't have no shady
stuff i've been using the prenatal for
such a long time now i'm a huge fan i
love how i can feel my body actually
absorbing the nutrients i don't feel my
body just like passing them through and
peeing them out or getting uh those
vitamin burps where i can really taste
like the fish oil and it tastes gross
like rituals just so clean and i my my
body
reacts really well to these vitamins and
they smell good i highly recommend them
exactly yeah the prenatal i think it's
citrus
and the the other one is like mint like
yeah or something like a mint yeah
exactly and then they're so cute too
they're golden pretty i love it i got a
little
yeah i love it so much that i got my my
13 year old son on the teen
multivitamins too
so uh right now ritual is offering our
listeners 10 off during your first three
months you can
com
visit
big mood and turn healthy habits into a
ritual yes that's 10 off at ritual.com
big mood don't forget ritual.com
big mood you know guys
sometimes doing less can lead to so much
more
oh where's this going
dipsy stories believes in less analyzing
and more feeling your feelings feel them
less stressing and more easing into that
ease into it
less scrolling and more time savoring
the moment savor that moment less
pressure
and more pleasure
pleasure are you guys doing the stories
stories is an app full of sexy audio
stories and now they even have brand new
written stories no matter who you're
into or what turns you on dipsy helps
bring the stories to life anytime
anywhere eminem stories no eminem
stories no matter what i mean no sorry
not for you
close your eyes and let yourself get
lost in a world where only good things
happen like eminem actually likes nikki
limo
and pleasure is your only priority
explore your fantasies in a safe
shame-free way because i won't be there
to shame you nicole yeah there's
hundreds of stories to choose from and
they release new content every week so
there's always more to explore yeah more
eminem stories
two m
m's oh wow that's a lot to explore and
they also have wellness sessions to help
you wind down and explore sleep sessions
to help you drift off
for our listeners dipsy's offering an
extended 30-day free trial when you go
to dipsystories.com
mood there's really no reason not to
check it out that's 30 days of full
access for free
when you go to dipsy that's d-i-p-s-e-a
stories dot com slash mood
dipsystories.com
all right so use those codes and um back
to this dick conversation
i have questions as uh i've been married
for for a while i've been you've been
out of the game i've been out of the
game for a while um but you know when i
was single going through i was
single for about eight months in between
relationships and i think i mean that
was like my quote-unquote whole face but
i didn't it's not like i hooked up with
a ton of people but i definitely had
that was the first time i'd ever like
had sex with guys
where i knew going into it like i don't
want a relationship with you i just am
horny and you make me laugh and i think
that you're kind of cute and right might
be a good time maybe we have some
chemistry but i know already that i
don't want a relationship with you
and i'm not in that space either to have
one um
i tell them that beforehand and
my feelings don't change after or at
least when i was doing it like one time
you're with the person no yeah i mean
well no because let's see there were
there were about like three or four guys
that this happened with where beforehand
like we had been flirting building up
the sexual tension you know being flirty
flirty flirty and then
finally the night comes where we're like
drinking and it's like it's go time
and i tell them like hey just so you
know this is just a hookup like i'm not
i don't want to date you like i i give
them the rules and they're like yeah
yeah yeah same same same
and then afterwards they want a
relationship or they keep trying to like
actually court me or date me well it's
probably just because you were like it's
never going to happen yeah so they're
like it's a challenge yeah maybe like
challenge accepted
but do you think it does that is that
what happens to you because for me it
was like a very clear line beforehand
like very clear like
i don't i can't see us together
i can't see us me like
wanting to celebrate your birthday with
you like i can't i can't see all those
couple things i can see you naked right
now yes
i can see your body on top of mine i can
feel the weight of you and like that
sounds pretty good yeah but i don't feel
like i ever want to like you don't want
to hold hands don't wear matching shoes
exactly exactly i think for me probably
the one the people that i've hooked up
with where i was like yeah i know this
guy like just on paper i already know
like you're not
i'm not that i'm better than anyone i
don't think i'm better than anyone but
just like we're not on the same page or
whatever it's not what you want yeah so
i think what happens is i really don't
get to know them that much so then i
fill in the blanks and i'm like because
the chemistry
floods me so
like maybe they could be but i'm like
but just because like the chat isn't
even there now i know it's not go for it
though huh how did you stop yourself
from still continuing because like i'm
listening to you guys right and i never
had yeah you never know like this is
like an alternate reality of like a
different dimension of what my life
could have been because for me i never
dated yeah i never was in this world
since 16 i've only been in three
relationships in one month in between
them so it's like i have the lowest
video i've ever [ __ ] met
doesn't mean my body count is no i'm
just kidding
so like your situation you just said um
is it's it
gives me a flashback to when
i had just gotten out of an engagement
i it was like one month of me finally
being single trying to figure out how to
be alone it was the hardest thing i had
my girlfriend sleep over with me because
like i was just like i cannot be alone
like i can't like i was scared i was
going to go back to my ex and i so i
almost moved to san diego to not go with
him like i was like [ __ ] you can't do
this and then meeting casey i was like
all right listen i just got an
engagement i don't want any relationship
i don't want nothing this isn't going
anywhere like don't don't pursue this
that same night he puts his hands on my
waist and i'm like what the [ __ ] dude i
said no right and then but then still
like i said the challenge was accepted i
still felt lonely i guess like i don't
know i was going through a lot and yeah
you're very vulnerable at that moment
yeah the most vulnerable yeah and then
so i still ended up being like okay fine
let's go have dinner and it was supposed
to be a group thing and but it ended up
just me being me and him and then i'm
like
so it's like a different dimension of
like what if i didn't
yeah like what if i ended up finding
that time for myself yeah
then like and then later reconnecting
with him yeah or whatever because like
we went through so much growth and like
so much like growing pains like oh my
god because you weren't healed yeah yeah
between the both of us because he was
like that too like serial monogamous and
like
not not really like ever being alone i
guess right but you were both willing to
work on it with each other you know no
right so i'm just like i i'm not saying
that i regret anything that's happening
i'm just like listening to you guys the
stories i'm sitting here really quiet
like really thinking like whoa different
dimension like what would that well just
like curiosity like i think i could like
separate
love and love sex yeah and i don't know
and that's why i was asking them well
you're not like the other girls no that
[ __ ] is hard no i was about to say this
is but this is how it felt for me like
to know the difference was we'd we'd had
sex right and then they want us they
would they tried to cuddle after or they
didn't why they want to spend the night
maybe they were doing maybe they were
like no trying too hard
no no no i physically felt like i was
going to throw up like yeah because they
were trying too hard i think no just
like them doing any sort of loving right
they were trying too hard because
usually when you hook up with a guy
that's like a player vibe like as soon
as you hook up he kind of cuts you off
like emotionally then you're like wait
what happened we were just [ __ ] like
and then they don't really text you or
something you know like there's a
different like those guys sound like
they wanted to be your boyfriend the
whole time and they're doing boyfriend
[ __ ] they weren't doing the hookup style
yeah but so like i could tell in my mind
that like
no like that this is not love like i
have no feelings for you i just wanted
yeah sex well
when i was in that mindset of like
literally cut separate the two because
that's all i wanted like i was
cold-blooded like i really was
cold-blooded i really didn't give a [ __ ]
but i also didn't want a relationship
now if you're hooking up with people and
you want a relationship you're already
kind of looking for something to hold on
to if your mind like they were already
latching right like yes she could feel
the latching yeah
that person so you know
the guys that aren't latching yeah yet
because you only had a couple yeah i'm
still
looking around
with a small number of guys yeah and
they were all latching types that guy
that the guy my ex was a [ __ ] boy guy
and i was like i wasn't like felt like i
wanted him
but we were together for two years so
i'm like
and that whole thing is uh we go towards
people we think uh like are a reflection
of us yeah right so if you keep [ __ ]
around with [ __ ] boys people like that's
probably what you were at the time maybe
or how you saw yourself or how you saw
yourself wanting to be like how you felt
you were supposed to be treated like
that's through the whole life yeah i
think that's what that is yeah for me so
so you want a relationship is that where
you're at me now yeah so and i didn't
have sex for 14 and a half months right
because i was like i need to change my
[ __ ] path because it was just fuckboy
after fuckboy yeah so okay so you want a
relationship yeah then celibate are you
selling a little bit now uh
[Applause]
i mean hollywood i mean not hollywood
halloween came and went
he gave he came and went human went but
um yeah so mostly still celibate though
so
99.9 so can i ask why that person made
you break your celibacy
he wasn't special at all it was my
choice i think because i think because i
was i don't think it had anything to do
with him okay like he was in place he
wasn't anything at all it was a
halloween weekend i had a mask on my
face like i literally painted myself i
was someone else for a moment i had
spent 14 and a half months being
physically alone mentally alone my soul
was alone and i think i just convinced
myself that like
if i go too long it's gonna get weird oh
okay you're not gonna know how to even
yeah
allow somebody to touch you yeah i was
like i don't want it to get we to a
point to where oh it's been like three
years and now it's weird like why so
long like what's wrong with you yeah
like so i guess in my head i was just
like well it's a special night it's a
it's a holiday yeah i'm not even myself
anymore you can't even see my face i'm
just like embodying a different spirit
right now i'm just gonna like kind of
knock the cobwebs off and then go back
to my life
and and just not feel so weird about it
because i felt like i was saving myself
for my next boyfriend who might be my
husband like i'll just say but then i'm
like well that's stupid because he's not
gonna do that and then i was just like
having these conversations right like
what am i really doing what's my goal
like what's what's okay what's not okay
why do i have rules for myself
why you know yeah like i don't know so
when you're going
like now you're dating right like just
dating i'm actively dating but like i'm
not
i'm like literally cutting off quick i'm
like relationship material no okay no no
second date like i'm not kind of like
pussyfooting around right like maybe
i'll [ __ ] like it's just like are you
husband material nope out okay so i'm
just like quick with what i'm doing and
also but i'm not sleeping with like
anyone yeah in a general sense are you
just like missing like physical touch
right now or is is do you feel because
you're searching for like a husband that
it's it seems so keeping you from your
boyfriend
and i'm like wait a minute but then it
could be [ __ ] three years before i
find a husband right then i'm never
gonna touch a man for a [ __ ] four
years yeah you i mean never ever thought
about like maybe just wanting to find
more like maybe like a
friend like i just don't think that i
can do that though okay you know what i
mean because like i i i don't
she starts filling in the gaps
but like i don't do that with this
i don't connect with people
very often so if i feel enough chemistry
then i'm just going to make you stay
it's kind of like like if i like 99 of
people i don't like i'm not
good with like i can collect a lot of
people mm-hmm so if i do like you then
you have to stay and if you don't then
what the [ __ ] you have to stay you're
mine yeah i like you
i don't like people you have to stay you
are now my person i know that about
myself so like i'm not gonna rope anyone
into that right so it's like if i it can
be one time i won't even [ __ ]
ask anything about you i'll cut like
we'll cut it out right now like with the
halloween guy like i'm not i haven't
spoken to him since yeah like so i'm
like that's fine but then like if i keep
having sex with him for like six weeks
i'm gonna be like you're dating now yeah
i mean yeah you're dating in my opinion
i'm like yeah that's the only if it's
just you and i and we text on a regular
basis are we together
do you know like that's not how people
play right now like that's how they then
you have the conversation like yo are we
exclusive and they're like no well then
every time then i think okay bye i'm
gonna have to cut this off for my own
well-being i don't even wanna get to the
point like because then you've had six
six weeks of like but then you're
getting attached no but that's all part
of it because you have to be able to be
vulnerable at some point and so you just
have to you know with sex that you might
be worried which look i think that's a
great boundary that you put for yourself
if you know sex is the gateway to your
heart even though it's like not really
connecting with your soul yeah close
close them legs and close that door
that's why i had to do that and which is
which is great and again that's being
self-aware yeah but you know you have a
lot of you've placed a lot of pressure
on yourself to find a husband yeah like
just even hearing that kind of gives me
anxiety a little bit because that sounds
like wow you really you know that's
great i just don't want anymore like
i've had so many relationships yeah
like when i stand so many casuals so i'm
like i don't you just gotta it's either
me alone yeah or the number one perfect
person yeah and then and i'm okay with
buying a loan at that point okay so at
least you know your options because you
literally are 50 50 either i'm gonna
have this person or i'm by myself yeah
and as long as you're solid with that
then your pursuit of finding that person
is that's what you gotta do you know
keep putting yourself in situations and
around people that
have the same
you know like have that
same goal because i know there are men
are out there that are looking for a
wife they're looking for somebody with
the same things that you're looking for
you just got to keep going to those
places and i think as long as you're
looking in the right spots then you and
with an open mind then
it should come your way but if like if
you're on tinder looking for a husband
no no
when when would you have the
conversation then about the exclusivity
um before having so so ideally i would
be dating them for at least four to six
weeks before having sex okay and then
and then you have sex and then you ask
me no before you ask about exclusivity
before sex oh see that's that would be
hard for me because i need to i need to
test the merchandise everyone before i
ever yeah everyone is different right
yeah
with someone who's also okay with it
yeah yeah and if i find out later that
they're lying then i'm like okay well we
started our relationship as a lie so
then we're gonna have to cut it off now
yeah yeah so it's just like if you if
you're dating me for six weeks and you
like me you're a man you've had plenty
of [ __ ] your whole life you can wait
six weeks if you're looking for your
wife totally and then if i say are you
seeing anyone else because i don't
really want to if we have sex and it's
terrible then we can have a conversation
be like look i don't think it's gonna
work but we don't have to [ __ ] before
you're gonna be like i'll give it a shot
yeah like so if we build an emotional
bond over six weeks you should be able
to say i'm interested in exclusivity
yeah and i
can then we can move forward and again
it's about finding like-minded people
yeah you know if somebody's like nah i
need to test it out first you see if
that's gonna work six weeks like we're
gonna be making out like if the kissing
is good
usually the sex is good but then like
also if you've already built up a
connection yo even if the d isn't solid
you can you can get around something
when you like someone because you know
think about it you're going to be with
the same person for the rest of your
life right you're going to have to
communicate that d ain't always going to
be bomb every time if you don't talk
about it or work through it i
haven't been in a situation where i've
worked through not good deed because we
broke up but i can't believe
i had good hopes but but like by then
i'm gonna see how big it is because i'm
gonna be yeah
[Applause]
but i've definitely been with
somebody that like sex was great
relationship bad then i've been with
somebody that like just as a person is
amazing sex was in but i love that
person so i'm like okay
we can work through this like i've
already i i care about you so much that
the connection is there that i'm still
going to be able to enjoy this because
it depends on your own personal
preference of priorities yes for some
other people like sex might be like that
has to be like perfect yeah yeah yeah
love languages you know right yeah
physical touch and good like that
chemistry you need that in order to be
okay
look i think i do which is hard for me
because
the the best sex for me is usually the
toxic sex so that's why i have to cut
myself off right to find a person that's
not going to bring the toxic side of me
out so it's like it's like a really hard
battle to fight a good person that's
also breaking their toxic habits is
willing to like then super freaking
but you gotta be good toxic past kind of
because they have to have the darkness
in them that i have in me i think
everybody can also be walking towards
the light it's a very difficult
situation very narrow like very
difficult
qualifications
it's okay for me yeah i've settled with
the fact that i could just be like a
spencer like i could be alone for the
rest of my life and like maybe just have
sex one off here and there and not
actually have a life partner because i'm
just so
that okay i know like boyfriend-wise
because i think boyfriend before i'm
thinking husband right now has the idea
of a husband to me right now i'm kind of
not really stressed i never really
saw myself married
from time to time like i can see it but
i don't it's not like a clear picture
for me but i think about a partner
that's like my main my main thing is i
want my person and when i i don't i
don't want to like love someone and then
they're going to like it's short-term
like i think for me because my parents
aren't married oh and they've been
together 33 years
yeah so for me yeah that part that's why
i say partner like i'm looking for my
person my partner i need but you want
that you're your lifestyle partner has
been as a partner yes okay yeah like how
people view like getting married and
that's their forever boyfriend seems
like it's only for a couple years though
so you're not you can evolve to right i
use that really loosely because i think
that there's steps to it yeah you know
i'm just like you know i don't think
that i'm going to meet somebody and he's
my husband now because i've thought that
and my heart was broken i don't think
that in the first week i'm going to know
that yeah you know what i mean well i
mean who knows
after a year but like yeah i still have
to meet the same level
mm-hmm like i'm not gonna
date someone and waste three years if i
if i don't think that they also meet my
definition of a husband yeah and again
everybody's timelines their definitions
are different because i don't really
have like say i meet somebody say i meet
somebody tomorrow
i'm like
i'm done
i'm done
to me like because i don't have you have
to keep it open-ended a little bit for
some me some flexibility yeah like
i adapt i've been battling with career
and relationship because i know family
wise like how i want to be how i am with
a relationship family is number one i
love
love
family and i want that one day and i
want that with the right person that i
can have my life that i'm living as far
as like being working and doing that and
then have the you know our chemistry and
whatnot but family is a top priority but
also i need them to be business oriented
as well so
i always say the retired player is like
the best in my opinion that to me is i
want that i do want somebody that's been
around the block i want somebody that
has already
explored and if you've seen everybody
and you've had the baddest [ __ ] and
you've been with the smartest women it
doesn't matter because if you're with me
and i'm all you want
i won because i did the same like i've
been around enough people if i'm gonna
settle down at this point and if i'm
gonna get in a relationship like you are
lucky as [ __ ] in my opinion my next
boyfriend is [ __ ] lucky or my next
person is going to be blessed to have me
in their life because i'm ready
because that's what i want and hopefully
that's the same thing with them but
you know it there is no timeline for me
but if you have your timeline and i
don't think there's a timeline like it
could be ten years from now that's why i
was like why am i just waiting so long
it's being celebrated i might as well
pop it again
[Music]
and here's the thing is you're the only
one that creates the rules yeah you're
the only one that wins and loses so
i'm not going to be oh my god yeah she
got dick yeah oh my god yeah you don't
broke your own rules yeah i'm gonna i'm
gonna have to spank you now police are
coming yeah something you broke your
rule that you made for yourself that
nobody told you to make yeah you know
because you're not living by anybody
else's standards and as long as you are
okay with if it works and if it doesn't
work then that's what you got to
continue to tell yourself every time say
it doesn't work you're like cool i'm not
losing because i already know what the
possibility of
being alone is and you're fine with it
and so i think you just telling yourself
that constantly is what's going to keep
you of avoiding those shitty ass people
yeah yeah exactly having you having your
own rules i'm yeah i have thoughts on
rules too because it's like
you don't want to feel like
you're going to beat yourself up and
come down in yourself and feel so guilty
if um you break this role that you meet
created for yourself but so
i think having a clear idea but then
being open to
like the like love is just not a science
it's like you don't get to choose who
you fall in love with like but you can
choose a husband yeah you can choose a
husband you choose a husband because you
can separate love sometimes something
will surprise you and it ends up being
better than yeah what you your uh what
you idealize but if you block it off
because you're so like mad at yourself
for breaking you know forgiveness but
yeah that's a whole that's a topic we
can explore i think um anyway i think
this conversation was amazing thank you
so much for rejoining us thank you blaze
coming back to the party and to answer
that girl's question really is like
forgiveness and even with yours you
gotta constantly forgive yourself and
that's but it's all a learning process
yeah and that's really what makes
there's no manual there is no manual and
you just gotta be okay with not being
perfect yeah
all right perfect go check out the
jewelry line some coffee also check out
nikki blades on her other podcast no
chaser
and you're the radio station 997 now big
bay mornings in san francisco shout out
bay area there you go nikki street eats
yes invites with blade checking out all
of the restaurants we got a lot of stuff
going on a lot of stuff going on you can
see why she's too busy to have a man
there we go you can check her out
and uh come come back for the other
episodes because there's quite a few
more with her so yeah
uh we'll see you then bye
[Music]
you